Probably the strangest thing about the K&R business-- K&R, that's Kidnap and Ransom-- is that it's a business at all, that there are enough kidnappings in the world that a whole industry issues kidnap insurance and there's responders who will help your family through the kidnapping and ransom process. And it's also workaday, like any other business.
关于绑架与勒索（K&R）业务，最奇怪的一点在于它竟然成了一门生意。世界上有足够多的绑架案件，以至于整个行业都在发行绑架保险，并且有专门的应对人员帮助受害者家属处理绑架和赎金谈判的过程。而且，它就像其他任何生意一样，是一份日常的工作。
My name is Daniel Johnson. I oversee Kidnap Response operations for a company called ASI Global. We do a lot of prevention work, which is training of Americans or executives.
我叫丹尼尔·约翰逊。我负责一家名为ASI Global的公司的绑架响应业务。我们做了大量的预防工作，主要是为美国人或企业高管提供培训。
ASI Global is one of the big American companies in the K&R business. And perhaps this just comes with the job, but Daniel Johnson is capable of a kind of understatement that's sort of breathtaking. For instance, he was telling me how K&R insurance works.
ASI Global是K&R业务中的美国大公司之一。也许这是职业使然，但丹尼尔·约翰逊有一种令人惊叹的轻描淡写的本事。例如，他在向我介绍K&R保险是如何运作的。
So if you were to have a Kidnap Response policy with traveler's insurance and something goes bump in the night, it's our company that gets that call.
所以，如果你投保了旅行者保险的绑架响应保单，而碰巧发生了意外，那我们公司就会接到那个电话。
By bump in the night, Dan means what you or I might call a violent, life-threatening, life-changing abduction. See? Understatement. Another interesting fact about kidnapping insurance with this company-- one condition of having the policy is that you don't tell anybody you have the policy. It's like the first rule of Fight Club.
丹所说的“意外”，指的是你我可能会称之为暴力、危及生命、改变人生的绑架。看到了吗？轻描淡写。关于这家公司的绑架保险，另一个有趣的事实是，拥有该保单的一个条件是，你不能告诉任何人你投保了。这就像《搏击俱乐部》的第一条规则。
OK, so let's say that I'm thinking about moving my radio show to a country where there are lots of kidnappings. You consult with people who are moving to those areas about what to do if you are kidnapped. If I'm kidnapped, give me advice. What should I do?
好的，假设我正在考虑把我的广播节目搬到一个有很多绑架案件的国家。你们会为那些搬到这些地区的人提供咨询，告诉他们如果被绑架该怎么办。如果我被绑架了，给我些建议。我该怎么做？
Well, most of the advice is going to be somewhat region or geographic specific. Some of the steps that we'd recommend for Mexico are obviously not the same steps you'd recommend for the Middle East or even Nigeria. Because of the Catholic culture in Mexico, we do recommend that the victims personalize themselves. Ask for a Bible.
嗯，大部分建议将取决于具体的区域或地理位置。我们在墨西哥推荐的一些措施，显然与你在中东甚至尼日利亚推荐的措施不同。由于墨西哥的天主教文化，我们建议受害者使自己个性化。要求得到一本圣经。
In the Mideast, he says, don't do this or talk about religion. But in Mexico, where there are lots of kidnappings these days--
他说，在中东，不要这样做，也不要谈论宗教。但在墨西哥，目前绑架事件频发——
It helps personalize you as some-- it's a basis of relation between you and the abductors.
这有助于让你个性化，作为你和绑匪之间建立联系的基础。
And it's to my advantage if they see me as a person, why?
如果他们把我视为一个人，那对我有什么好处，为什么？
Contrary to popular belief and some of the myths, kidnappers, in most cases, don't wantonly, with no reason whatsoever, go in and abuse the victims. Unfortunately, it does happen in some instances. Well, the more personal you are to them, the more that they can relate to you, the less likely that's going to happen, the better care that they're going to give.
与普遍的看法和一些传言相反，绑匪在大多数情况下，并不是无缘无故地去虐待受害者的。不幸的是，这种情况确实在某些实例中发生。嗯，你表现得越人性化，他们就越能与你产生共鸣，这种情况发生的可能性就越小，他们给你的照顾也会越好。
The other advantage of a Bible, Dan says, is that you might be captive for a long time. And one of the big problems in that situation is it's really, really boring. People get depressed. They stop taking care of themselves. Some of them think about suicide. So it's important to keep your mind active, to create a routine of things that you do every day, not to sleep all day, which lots of people end up doing. And if you have a Bible, you can read, which is huge.
丹说，圣经的另一个好处是，你可能会被囚禁很长时间。在这种情况下，最大的问题之一是真的很无聊。人们会变得沮丧。他们停止照顾自己。有些人会想到自杀。所以保持头脑活跃很重要，要建立每天要做的事情的常规，不要整天睡觉，很多人的最终结局就是那样。如果你有一本圣经，你可以阅读，这非常有意义。
Other tips-- eat what they give you because it's probably the same food that they're eating. Drink the water. Don't try to escape. Don't look your captors in the eye.
其他建议——吃他们给你的东西，因为这很可能就是他们自己吃的食物。喝水。不要试图逃跑。不要盯着绑匪的眼睛看。
Sometimes it's viewed as being confrontational with the captors. And you want to be somewhat non-confrontational.
有时这会被视为与绑匪对立。而你想要表现得相对不那么对立。
Are there counterintuitive things that you tell people to do?
有没有什么反直觉的建议是你告诉人们去做的？
Yes. Some of the recommendations we give are counterintuitive. For example, most kidnap victims-- or not most, but many kidnap victims, when they are first captured, feel that their life is in danger so they need to negotiate for themselves. So what they start to do is they start talking about my company made $10 million last year and I'm a senior manager with my company. And my wife has a half million dollars in a 401K.
是的。我们给出的一些建议是反直觉的。例如，大多数绑架受害者——或者说不是大多数，而是许多绑架受害者，在最初被抓时，觉得自己的生命处于危险之中，所以他们认为需要为自己谈判。于是他们开始谈论我的公司去年赚了1000万美元，我是公司的高级经理。我的妻子在401K退休账户里有50万美元。
That doesn't help the negotiation process. That raises the expectations of the kidnappers, so what we typically recommend is you don't have financial conversations at all with your captors.
那对谈判过程没有帮助。这会提高绑匪的预期，所以我们通常建议，你根本不要与绑匪进行财务对话。
But that's hard to do, he says. Your instinct is that you want to trade away everything just to get your life back. You'll do anything. But you have to understand, if it's a kidnapping for ransom-- and one sign of that is that you're still alive-- that's like a business deal, and they need you alive to make their money.
但他表示，这很难做到。你的本能是想要放弃一切来换回你的生命。你会做任何事。但你必须明白，如果这是一次勒索绑架——其中一个迹象是你还活着——那就像是一笔生意，他们需要你活着来赚钱。
And usually, Dan says, you're going to get out. It's just a matter of coming to a price. You have to remember that. And you have to remember that your role in that business deal is to be the hostage, to do what you need to do to survive, to avoid panic.
丹说，通常情况下，你会获救。这只是一个谈价格的问题。你必须记住这一点。你必须记住，你在那笔生意中扮演的角色是人质，去做你需要做的事情来生存，避免恐慌。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our radio show, Held Hostage. We have three stories for you of people who are forced by circumstance to be the hostage and how they cope with what that means. We're going to begin with people held in the traditional way, nabbed and taken to the jungle.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的广播节目是“被扣为人质”。我们有三个关于人们因境况所迫成为人质的故事，以及他们如何应对由此带来的后果。我们先从那些以传统方式被扣押、被抓走并带到丛林里的人讲起。
But we also have people in our show who are taken hostage in much less literal ways. One man can't get out from under the thumb of one of his neighbors. And we have a man held hostage by love, and I know that sounds really corny, but believe me, it is not what you think. Stay with us.
但我们的节目中也有人以不那么字面的方式被扣为人质。一个人无法摆脱邻居的控制。还有一个男人被爱所扣为人质，我知道这听起来很俗气，但相信我，它并不像你想的那样。请留下来。
Act One, Captive Audience. So today's episode is a rerun from 2010. And at that time, nearly a decade ago, there was so much kidnapping going on in Colombia, that the country's biggest radio station had a program that was specifically for kidnapping victims. Like, it was targeted to them as an audience. And this was not the only show like this. There were several other shows like this on smaller stations, again, whose audience was kidnapping victims around the country.
第一幕，被俘虏的听众。所以今天的节目是2010年的重播。在那个时候，大约十年前，哥伦比亚发生的绑架事件非常多，以至于该国最大的广播电台有一个专门为绑架受害者制作的节目。也就是说，它的受众目标就是他们。而且这并不是唯一的此类节目。在规模较小的电台上还有其他几个类似的节目，同样，它们的受众也是全国各地的绑架受害者。
Annie Correal is originally from Bogota, Colombia. And she went to the biggest radio station and visited the program.
安妮·科雷亚尔来自哥伦比亚波哥大。她去了那家最大的广播电台并参观了这个节目。
The show is called Voces del Secuestro-- Voices of Kidnapping-- and it's been on the big national station in Colombia, Caracol, since 1994.
这个节目叫《绑架之声》，自1994年以来一直在哥伦比亚国家级大电台Caracol播出。
[MUSIC - JUANES, "SUENOS"]
[音乐 - 胡安内斯，《梦》]
Starting at midnight every Saturday and running until 6:00 AM, hundreds of people call in to send messages to their kidnapped relatives. And in secret camps all through the jungle, prisoners, and sometimes even their guards, tune in to listen.
从每周六午夜开始一直持续到早上6点，数百人打电话给被绑架的亲人发送信息。在丛林各处的秘密营地里，囚犯们，有时甚至是看守们，也会收听这个节目。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
The host kicks off the show welcoming all the hostages in the jungles of Colombia. Most families call in with their messages.
主持人开场欢迎所有在哥伦比亚丛林中被扣为人质的人。大多数家庭打电话来发送他们的信息。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
But some people actually come into the station like Viviana. Her dad, Edgar Yasid Duarte, is a police commander who was kidnapped in 1998 and still hasn't come home.
但有些人确实像维维安娜一样来到了电台。她的父亲埃德加·亚西德·杜阿尔特是一名警察指挥官，于1998年被绑架，至今尚未回家。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
Tomorrow is Viviana's 13th birthday, and rather than run the risk of not getting on the air, she and her mom are spending the night at the radio station. A dozen interns man flashing phone banks, lining up the callers from around the country who will send out their messages tonight.
明天是维维安娜的13岁生日，为了不冒上不了节目的风险，她和她妈妈在电台过夜。十几名实习生在闪烁的电话银行前操作，为今晚要发送信息的全国各地的来电者排队。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
170 will make it on the air.
170个电话能够接通播出。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
Viviana is in a pink hoodie, drinking little cups of coffee from the vending machine to stay awake. She always sends a message to mark her birthday. It's 5:00 in the morning when she finally gets on the air.
维维安娜穿着粉红色的连帽衫，喝着自动售货机里的小杯咖啡以保持清醒。她总是会发一条信息来纪念她的生日。当她最终轮到播出时，已经是凌晨5点了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
She says her birthday's an important day in their lives, and she just knows he's going to be there, that they're going to free him this year so he won't miss any more special dates. She says she celebrated with her friends by going to a shopping mall and to the movies and to get ice cream. She tells him she loves him, and she sends him a blessing.
她说她的生日是他们生命中重要的一天，她坚信他会在那里，他们今年会释放他，这样他就不会再错过任何特别的日子。她说她和朋友们去商场看电影和吃冰淇淋庆祝了。她告诉他她爱他，并送给他一个祝福。
I know how she feels. When I was 19, my dad was kidnapped by the FARC, the same rebel group that kidnapped Viviana's dad. The FARC is an army of leftist guerrillas that kidnaps people for political reasons, but also civilians like my dad, for money. My dad, Jaime Correal, was kidnapped on his way home from work in 1999.
我理解她的感受。我19岁那年，我父亲被哥伦比亚革命武装力量（FARC）绑架了，就是那个绑架维维安娜父亲的同一个反叛组织。FARC是一支左翼游击队军队，出于政治原因绑架人，但也为了钱绑架像我父亲这样的平民。我的父亲杰米·科雷亚尔，在1999年下班回家的路上被绑架了。
There was a guy on a motorcycle back there. But I didn't think anything of it. I didn't notice I was being followed.
后面有一辆摩托车。但我没在意。我没注意到我被跟踪了。
This year when I went back to Colombia, my dad and I drove through a park, up a winding, isolated road to the spot on the highway where it happened.
今年我回到哥伦比亚时，我和父亲开车穿过一个公园，沿着一条蜿蜒、偏僻的道路来到高速公路上事发的地方。
And right where I'm standing, the guy came from behind that pole, and he came with a gun up, was screaming, "Police, police." I tried to get into the traffic, and I couldn't get in because it was bumper to bumper. And that's when they hit the window, and they pulled me out, and they threw me in the backseat with two guys with a weapon.
就在我站的地方，那个人从杆子后面出来，带着枪，尖叫着：“警察，警察。”我试图进入车流，但进不去，因为车子一辆接一辆。就在那时，他们砸了窗户，把我拉了出来，并把我扔进了后座，有两个拿着武器的人在里面。
Back then, Colombia was the kidnapping capital of the world. At the peak of the kidnapping craze, there were around 3,000 people kidnapped a year. That's like eight people a day. Carjackings happen in Bogota all the time and in plain view, like my dad's.
那时，哥伦比亚是世界绑架之都。在绑架狂潮的高峰期，一年大约有3000人被绑架。相当于一天8个人。在波哥大，像我父亲那样在众目睽睽之下被劫车的事件时有发生。
You know, I had in my mind that it was not so close to the road, but it's right there.
你知道，我心目中以为它离公路没那么近，但它就在那里。
Is that the first time you've been back to that spot?
这是你第一次回到那个地方吗？
Uh-huh. Yep.
嗯。是的。
As we sat in the spot where it happened, he said if he had taken a left, it would have taken him 20 minutes to get home.
当我们坐在事发地点时，他说如果他当时左转，20分钟就能到家。
Instead it took me eight and a half months, 265 days.
结果我花了八个半月，265天。
While my dad was kidnapped, I was in college in the States. But my stepmom Sammy used to call into the radio show, Voices of Kidnapping, to try to reach him. Six months in, when the guerrillas arranged a phone call with my dad, she learned to her amazement that some of our messages actually got through. My dad had had a radio and had listened for us obsessively.
在我父亲被绑架时，我在美国上大学。但我继母萨米经常给那个广播节目《绑架之声》打电话，试图联系他。六个月后，当游击队员安排了我父亲的一次通话时，她惊讶地发现，我们的一些信息确实传达出去了。我父亲有一台收音机，一直在狂热地听我们的信息。
It was a black machine. I don't know. It wasn't a brand name that everybody knows. It was something like cauliflower, OK? I mean, it was as valuable as my cigarettes, OK? And something I would wrap really well with my clothes in a plastic bag so they wouldn't get wet.
那是一台黑色的机器。我不知道。不是大家熟知的品牌。像是花椰菜什么的，好吗？我的意思是，它和我口袋里的香烟一样珍贵，好吗？我会用衣服把它包在塑料袋里，这样它们就不会被弄湿。
And reception was very bad. We were in the deep jungle, so we learned from the guerrillas how to make antennas. We would steal the Brillo pad, the used ones, when we went by the kitchen. The Brillo pad, you untangle it, and you make a big line of wire. You get a stone, wrap it up in one of the ends, and you throw it up into the trees. That helped tremendously.
而且接收效果非常差。我们在丛林深处，所以我们从游击队员那里学会了如何制作天线。当我们经过厨房时，我们会偷用过的钢丝球。你把钢丝球解开，做成一条长长的电线。你找块石头，缠在一端，把它扔进树林里。这非常有帮助。
A guard snuck the radio to my dad. They're not officially allowed, but the FARC lets prisoners listen because it keeps up morale. It keeps them from killing themselves, and it keeps them marching. My dad was moved 37 times during his captivity. The radio meant everything to him because for the first six months that he was held captive by the FARC, my dad was held alone, completely alone. The radio was his only companion.
一名看守悄悄给了我父亲那台收音机。官方是不允许的，但FARC允许囚犯收听，因为这能提振士气。它能防止他们自杀，并能让他们继续行军。在囚禁期间，我父亲被转移了37次。收音机对他来说意味着一切，因为在我父亲被FARC关押的前六个月里，他是一个人，完全是一个人。收音机是他唯一的同伴。
It's really an exercise of patience to be awake for 12 hours, 13 hours, and not being able to do anything. You can do anything. Sometimes you see all those movies. Like, Rambo just exercises when he's in jail. And you say, well, I'm going to start exercising, and you exercise, but you get bored. You start getting in shape, let me tell you.
清醒着待上12、13个小时却什么也做不了，这确实是对耐心的锻炼。你什么也做不了。有时你看那些电影，比如兰博在监狱里锻炼。你说，好吧，我要开始锻炼，你就锻炼，但你感到无聊。让我告诉你，你开始变得身体强壮。
But mentally, you feel you're wasting your time. I was by myself between November that I was kidnapped until May 26. I could talk to the guards very little. They're not supposed to talk to you. But then at night, then you rewind your whole life.
但在精神上，你会觉得你在浪费时间。从11月我被绑架到5月26日，我都是一个人。我很少能和看守说话。他们不应该和你说话。但到了晚上，你就开始重温你的一生。
How was that?
那感觉如何？
That was scary. Because you start judging yourself. Mostly what comes to mind is what you think you did wrong-- wrong decisions that could have made a difference in your life. But it's being alone with all those ghosts.
那很可怕。因为你开始审判自己。脑子里出现的主要是你认为自己做错的事情——那些可能会改变你人生的错误决定。但那是独自与所有这些幽灵在一起。
So when he first heard my stepmom, Sammy, talking to him over the radio, it was like a miracle.
所以当他第一次在收音机里听到我继母萨米和他说话时，那就像是一个奇迹。
You know, it was like 6:20 in the morning. I was laying in bed with my radio. It said, "This is a message for Jaime Correal." I mean, my heart stopped. I said, "Wow." She said, "Your kids are fine. Hold up. Pray." You know, all the encouraging words they can give you. So from now on, that was my lifeline.
你知道，当时大约是早上6:20。我躺在床上拿着收音机。它说：“这是给杰米·科雷亚尔的信息。”我的心跳停止了。我说，“哇。”她说，“你的孩子们很好。坚强。祈祷。”你知道，所有他们能给你的鼓励的话。从那时起，那就是我的生命线。
My dad would stay up all night listening to the show every week.
我父亲每周都会彻夜不眠地听这个节目。
A lot of times, you lose to the station because actually, you're always deep in the jungle, and there's a lot of clouds. And then you just go very softly trying to locate it again. And then you don't want to move the radio, so you end up in these awkward positions and just listening. When they call your name, when they mention your name, your heart always pounds.
很多时候，你会错过电台，因为你总是在丛林深处，有很多云。然后你只能轻轻地再次尝试定位它。然后你不想移动收音机，所以你最终处于这些尴尬的姿势中，只是在听。当他们叫到你的名字，当他们提到你的名字时，你的心总是怦怦直跳。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
This is a radio message from my family recorded 10 years ago when my dad was held captive. My stepmom made this tape to send to the radio station, hoping he would hear it, wherever he was. In real life, she was struggling to hold it together, losing weight, dark circles under her eyes. But on the tape, she makes a point to be cheerful. She calls him by his nickname, Lumpy.
这是我家人10年前在我父亲被囚禁时录制的一条广播信息。我继母制作了这段录音并寄给广播电台，希望无论他在哪里都能听到。在现实生活中，她努力支撑着自己，体重下降，眼眶深陷。但在录音中，她特意表现得欢快。她叫他绰号“Lumpy”。
My Lumpy, [SPEAKING SPANISH]
我的Lumpy，[西班牙语发言]
[MUSIC - SHANIA TWAIN, "FROM THIS MOMENT ON"]
[音乐 - 仙妮亚·唐恩，《从这一刻起》]
She chose one of her favorite love songs to mix with the radio message.
她选了她最喜欢的爱情歌曲之一，混入广播信息中。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
She says every time she hears it, she thinks of him intensely. She asks if he can imagine how much they're going to enjoy making up for lost time. Then she introduces my little sister.
她说每当她听到这首歌，她就会强烈地想起他。她问他能不能想象他们将多么享受弥补失去的时间。然后她介绍了我的小妹妹。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
My little sister says she hopes he comes back soon safe and sound and that he'll be very, very, very hungry because they'll have his favorite-- eggs and sausage-- waiting for him. Then my brother comes on.
我的小妹妹说她希望他能早日平安归来，并且他会非常、非常、非常饿，因为他们会准备好他最喜欢的东西——鸡蛋和香肠——等着他。然后我哥哥登场。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
He says he's the goalie on the school soccer team and he's blocked a lot of shots. Then he says he loves him and misses him. My stepmom says that she's waiting for him, that she'll always wait for him and he's the love of her life. And she can't wait to pick up where they left off in November.
他说他是学校足球队的守门员，他挡出了很多射门。然后他说他爱他，很想念他。我继母说她在等他，她会永远等他，他是她一生所爱。她迫不及待地想从11月中断的地方继续。
I love you. [SPEAKING SPANISH] [KISS] Ciao, ciao! [SPEAKING SPANISH]
我爱你。[西班牙语发言][吻] 再见，再见！[西班牙语发言]
The families on Voices of Kidnapping are coached not to say anything negative or cry, so there tends to be a lot of talk of holiday parties and kids' grades at school, weddings, new babies in the family. These days, the number of new kidnappings in Colombia is way down. There are just a few hundred a year. And that's a good thing. But it conceals something basic.
《绑架之声》上的家庭被告知不要说负面的话或哭泣，所以往往有很多关于节日聚会、孩子学校成绩、婚礼、家中新生儿的谈话。这些天，哥伦比亚的新绑架案数量大幅下降。一年只有几百起。这是一件好事。但这掩盖了一些基本的东西。
The fact is that thousands of people who are kidnapped never came back. There are thousands of families who are still waiting for their relatives to be released, like Viviana, the girl who was celebrating her 13th birthday at the radio station. Viviana's dad has been gone for 11 years, almost her entire life. He's part of a small group of political prisoners that the FARC won't free unless the government agrees to a prisoner exchange. So there's nothing the family can do but wait.
事实是，成千上万被绑架的人从未回来。有成千上万个家庭仍在等待他们的亲人获释，就像维维安娜，那个在广播电台庆祝她13岁生日的女孩。维维安娜的父亲已经失踪11年了，几乎是她的一生。他是FARC拒绝释放的一小群政治犯之一，除非政府同意交换囚犯。所以除了等待，家人什么也做不了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
Everything Viviana knows about her dad fits easily on top of a coffee table. There's a pile of notebooks filled with his colored pencil drawings, the rusted aviator glasses he was wearing when he was kidnapped, and a few photographs and videos the FARC has sent as proof he is alive. Vienna was so young when her dad was kidnapped, that her only images of him come from these photos and videos.
维维安娜关于父亲的所有记忆都可以轻松地摆在咖啡桌上。那是一堆笔记本，里面装满了他的彩色铅笔画，他被绑架时戴的生锈的飞行员眼镜，以及FARC送来的几张证明他还活着的照片和视频。维维安娜父亲被绑架时她太小了，以至于她对他唯一的印象都来自这些照片和视频。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
She says that he's in the jungle, but it's impossible to know where because he's posed against a sheet. I remember getting one of those pictures. They call it a [SPEAKING SPANISH] a proof of life. It's like seeing something from another world-- my dad next to a tree in sweatpants and a peasant sweater. My dad is a prisoner. I asked Viviana what her dad looked like in those proofs of life.
她说他在丛林里，但不可能知道在哪里，因为他是站在一块布前摆拍的。我记得收到过其中一张照片。他们称之为[西班牙语发言]活着证明。这就像看到来自另一个世界的东西——我的父亲站在一棵树旁，穿着运动裤和农民毛衣。我父亲是一名囚犯。我问维维安娜，她的父亲在那些活着证明中看起来怎么样。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
She says in the older photos, he used to look normal, chubby. But in the recent videos, he's looking thin and he's going bald. She says that's hard because he used to look stronger. She says she thinks to herself, no, why is he like that? Life is hard, she says.
她说在较旧的照片中，他看起来很正常，胖乎乎的。但在最近的视频中，他看起来很瘦，而且正在秃顶。她说那很难受，因为他过去看起来更强壮。她说她心想，不，为什么他会变成那样？她说，生活真难。
To cope, Viviana still talks to her dad, and not just over the radio.
为了应对，维维安娜仍然和她父亲说话，而且不仅仅是通过广播。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
She says it's not that she feels he's here. She says she talks to him in her head.
她说并不是她觉得他在这里。她说她在脑子里和他说话。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
I talked to my dad in my head, too. I consulted him about what to major in, and I asked for his help at exam time. When my mood would plummet, I would think it was somehow connected to what he was going through. And in the worst moments, when I wouldn't feel his presence, I'd look outside and say, if he's alive, let there be a sign in the next 60 seconds. And I'd count down. And inevitably, a dog would bark, or a street light would turn on.
我也在脑子里和我父亲说话。我咨询他大学该选什么专业，考试时我也请求他的帮助。当我情绪低落时，我会觉得这以某种方式与他正在经历的事情有关。在最糟糕的时刻，当我感觉不到他的存在时，我会看向窗外，说，如果他还活着，让我在接下来的60秒内看到一个信号。然后我会倒数。结果，总会有一只狗叫，或者路灯亮起。
It's like sending the radio messages. You send these little telepathic messages, you concentrate, and you start to believe someone is out there, listening. I've met families who haven't had a proof of life for five years or a decade. Their loved ones are probably dead, but they act like they're not. They send out messages to them week after week, hoping that they're out there in the dark, holding a radio.
这就像发送广播信息。你发送这些小小的超感官信息，你集中精神，然后你开始相信外面有人在听。我遇到过五年或十年都没有收到活着证明的家庭。他们的亲人很可能已经死了，但他们表现得像他们还活着一样。他们一遍又一遍地发送信息给他们，希望他们还在外面的黑暗中，拿着一台收音机。
Annie Correal, she's a staff reporter for The New York Times. You sometimes hear her on the podcast, The Daily. She originally produced a version of this show with Jay Allison for transom.org. I have to say, a lot has changed since we first aired this story in 2010. Annie's dad was rescued by the Colombian military, along with five other hostages, in August 2000. The family moved to Panama, which is where her dad, Jaime Correal, died in 2016 after a short illness. He was 63.
安妮·科雷亚尔是《纽约时报》的一名职员记者。你有时能在播客《每日》中听到她的声音。她最初与Jay Allison为transom.org制作了这个节目的一个版本。我必须说，自从我们2010年首次播出这个故事以来，很多事情都改变了。安妮的父亲与另外五名人质在2000年8月被哥伦比亚军队救出。全家搬到了巴拿马，她的父亲杰米·科雷亚尔于2016年因病去世。他享年63岁。
That girl who Annie interviewed, Viviana-- her dad, Edgar Yasid Duarte, was killed by the FARC during a failed rescue attempt in 2011. He'd been held captive for 13 years. Viviana is in college now studying international relations. The FARC disbanded in 2016 as part of a peace deal with the Colombian government. After that, the radio show Voces del Secuestro came to an end. Its final episode was in 2018. Similar programs with messages for hostages also ended.
安妮采访的那个女孩维维安娜——她的父亲埃德加·亚西德·杜阿尔特在2011年一次失败的营救行动中被FARC杀害。他被囚禁了13年。维维安娜现在大学在读，学习国际关系。FARC在2016年作为与哥伦比亚政府和平协议的一部分解散了。在那之后，广播节目《绑架之声》结束了。它的最后一期是在2018年。类似的为人质发送信息的节目也结束了。
Coming up, taken hostage by somebody whose only weapon is paperwork. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，被一个唯一的武器是文书工作的人扣为人质。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Held Hostage. In this second half of our program, we move to people who get held hostage without a gun, or a knife, or any kind of traditional captor, and then they have to figure out what to do. We have arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, Misdeeds.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的不同类型的故事。今天的节目是“被扣为人质”。在我们节目的下半部分，我们转向那些没有枪、刀或任何传统绑架者却被扣为人质的人，然后他们不得不弄清楚该怎么办。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，不法行为。
This is a kind of classic story of people who are not looking for trouble, and then the trouble came looking for them. Wayne Curtis tells the story.
这是一个经典的寻找麻烦却被麻烦找上门的故事。韦恩·柯蒂斯讲述了这个故事。
11 years ago, Tracy Poydras and her husband, Oscar, were living in New Orleans. Tracy was a nurse in her late 20s. Her husband ran a nightclub in the city. They were planning for their future, and they decided to invest in a house. They checked out a city program that seizes blighted properties and sells them cheap, and they found a rundown duplex in a decent neighborhood. It was basically just a shell with four walls and a roof and not much of a floor, and they spent something like $50,000 or $60,000 fixing it up.
11年前，特蕾西·波德拉斯和她的丈夫奥斯卡住在新奥尔良。特蕾西是一位20多岁的护士。她的丈夫在城里经营一家夜总会。他们正在规划未来，决定投资一所房子。他们查看了政府的一个项目，该项目没收荒废的房产并低价出售，他们发现了一个位于体面社区的破旧复式住宅。那基本上只是一个四壁加屋顶的外壳，甚至没有像样的地板，他们花了大约5万或6万美元将其修缮。
For a while, they lived in one unit and rented out the other. Then they moved out and rented both. The whole process went just as they'd hoped, until 2003, when, pretty much out of the blue, Tracy Poydras got a call from her tenants.
有一段时间，他们住在一个单元里，把另一个租了出去。后来他们搬走了，把两个都租了出去。整个过程进展得正如他们所愿，直到2003年，几乎毫无征兆地，特蕾西·波德拉斯接到了她租客的电话。
They get eviction notices on the upstairs portion and the down. And they're calling us, hysterical. And they're like, what is going on? We've paid our rent. I mean, do we have some kind of problem? I mean, I didn't think we had a problem.
他们在楼上和楼下的部分都收到了驱逐通知。他们歇斯底里地给我们打电话，问到底发生了什么事？我们已经付了租金。我的意思是，我们有什么问题吗？我不认为我们有什么问题。
The eviction papers have been filed by a person who used to own the building, a guy named Nathaniel Dowl. Tracy figured it was a misunderstanding of some sort, that Dowl was probably just confused and didn't understand that the city had seized his property and sold it to somebody new.
驱逐文书是由该建筑物的前主人，一个叫纳撒尼尔·道尔的人提交的。特蕾西以为这是一种误解，道尔可能只是困惑，不明白政府已经没收了他的房产并卖给了新主人。
Whatever it was, she was sure a simple explanation would clear things up with Mr. Dowl. She was wrong. And pretty soon, Tracy and her husband found themselves in court and, for the first time, came face-to-face with Dowl and his wife, Barbara.
不管是什么，她肯定简单的解释就能和道尔先生说清楚。她错了。很快，特蕾西和她的丈夫发现自己被卷入了诉讼，并第一次与道尔和他的妻子芭芭拉面对面。
I don't know if they had just flown in from a Jamaican retreat or what, but Ms. Dowl had on a tie-dye shirt and jeans, just clearly not dressed for business, not dressed for court. And Mr. Dowl was reeking of marijuana. Reeking. Just to have the nerve to come in there like that, I just knew that something wasn't right, you know? Something was definitely not right.
我不知道他们是不是刚从牙买加的度假胜地飞回来，还是怎么的，但道尔女士穿着扎染衬衫和牛仔裤，显然没有为工作穿衣，也没有为法庭打扮。道尔先生浑身散发着大麻味。令人作呕。仅仅有胆量那样出现在那里，我就知道有什么不对劲，你知道吗？有什么肯定不对劲。
After a long day in court, the judge asked the Dowls for proof that they owned the building. The Dowls couldn't come up with any. The judge stopped the eviction. And for a while at least, everything was OK. A year went by. Life returned to normal.
在法庭上度过漫长的一天后，法官要求道尔夫妇出示他们拥有该建筑的证明。道尔夫妇拿不出来。法官停止了驱逐。至少有一段时间，一切都还正常。一年过去了。生活回到了正轨。
Then Hurricane Katrina hit, and the levees failed. The house the Poydras's had fixed up was now in shambles. Flooding destroyed the first floor, and the wind ripped off the roof. Tracy and her husband hired contractors to start fixing up the place all over again. But then, not long after, the contractor said weird things started happening around the site.
然后飓风卡特里娜袭来，堤坝决堤了。波德拉斯夫妇修缮的房子现在变成了一片废墟。洪水摧毁了第一层，风掀掉了屋顶。特蕾西和她的丈夫雇佣了承包商开始重新修缮这个地方。但不久后，承包商说现场开始发生奇怪的事情。
Well, and they would notice that a hammer would be missing. And then maybe the next day, the hammer would come back. I mean, just like anything like a crazy Lifetime Movie, just all kind of stuff. And then one day, someone with no rhyme or reason, just someone with, like, schizophrenia kind of had tape just all over the place, just, like, yellow caution tape. It was just everywhere. And they were like, you got to find out what's really going on here.
嗯，他们会注意到一把锤子不见了。也许第二天，锤子又回来了。我的意思是，就像任何疯狂的终身电影一样，各种各样的东西。有一天，有人毫无道理，就像精神分裂症患者一样，到处贴满了胶带，就是黄色的警戒胶带。到处都是。他们说，你得查清楚这里到底发生了什么。
So the next couple of days, I went into New Orleans to try to see if maybe the code enforcement or somebody like that had something to do with it. So then when I went in to the real estate-- I forget which office it's called, but they're the ones that handle the evictions. And I told them my name and my property address, and they were, like, sighing. They were like, oh goodness. Go cross-reference your name.
接下来的几天，我去了新奥尔良，试图看看是不是代码执行官或者是类似的人做的。当我进入房地产——我忘记那个办公室叫什么了，但他们负责驱逐。我报了我的名字和物业地址，他们叹了口气。他们说，噢，天哪。去交叉参考你的名字。
Tracy didn't know it just then, but she had company and plenty of it. Other people across the city were finding that weird things were happening, both with their properties and with the paperwork behind their properties. One of those people was a tall, fairly reserved ex-army officer named Brad Robinson. At the time all this started, he and Tracy Poydras had never met and they traveled in different worlds. But they both had decided that buying up cheap New Orleans property made good sense.
特蕾西当时不知道，她有同伴，而且很多。整个城市的其他人也发现，无论是在他们的房产上，还是在房产背后的文书工作上，都发生了奇怪的事情。其中一个人是一位身材高大、相当内敛的退役陆军军官，名叫布拉德·罗宾逊。在这所有的一切开始时，他和特蕾西·波德拉斯从未见过面，他们生活在不同的世界。但他们都认为买下便宜的新奥尔良房产是有道理的。
Shortly after Brad got out of the army, he and his wife, Michelle, started a business rehabbing blighted old houses and building new ones. In 2004, they'd spotted a house in the city's list of seized buildings, so Brad wrote down the address, 8633 Zimple Street, and drove over to check it out.
布拉德退伍后不久，他和妻子米歇尔开了一家翻新荒废老房子并建造新房子的公司。2004年，他们在城市没收建筑的名单上看到了一所房子，所以布拉德记下了地址，Zimple街8633号，开车去查看。
And that's where I recently met up with Brad. He was waiting there with a stack of photos to show me what the house looked like when he bought it. It was a mess. The grass was several feet high, and vines covered it like an ill-fitting toupee. The back part of the house was collapsing, and from what I could tell from the pictures, the only thing holding up part of it was an old refrigerator.
最近我在那里遇到了布拉德。他带着一叠照片等在那里，向我展示他买下时房子的样子。那真是一团糟。草长了好几英尺高，藤蔓像一顶不合身的假发一样覆盖着它。房子的后面部分正在坍塌，从照片上看，唯一支撑它一部分的是一台旧冰箱。
It was so bad that Robinson couldn't imagine anyone would possibly be living in it, much less that the owner would drive up as he stood there, slam his car door, and storm over to him. It was Nathaniel Dowl, the guy who had shown up in court reeking of marijuana.
情况太糟糕了，罗宾逊无法想象会有人住在里面，更不用说当他站在那里时，业主开车过来，猛地关上车门，冲向他。那是纳撒尼尔·道尔，那个在法庭上浑身散发着大麻味出现在那里的人。
And he said, who are you? And I identified myself. And I said, I found this house on the city's website, and I was looking at purchasing it. And I told him. I said, if you want to keep it, you've got to do two things. Number one, you've got to clean it up. And two, I said, you've got to go down and pay your taxes because you've got maybe seven years, or whatever it was, in taxes that were delinquent. And at first, he was kind of belligerent the first time I met him. And then once I tried to help him and I told what he needed to do to fix the problem, he was talking to me like a friend.
他说，你是谁？我报了身份。我说，我在城市网站上发现了这所房子，我正考虑购买。我告诉了他。我说，如果你想保留它，你必须做两件事。第一，你必须清理它。第二，我说，你必须去交税，因为你欠税可能有七年了，或者是多少年。起初，我第一次见到他时他还有点好战。然后一旦我试图帮助他，并告诉他修复问题需要做什么，他就开始像朋友一样和我谈话。
Brad actually had a few things in common with Nathaniel Dowl. Both were born and raised in New Orleans. Both were in their 40s. Both were from families that had once bought investment properties here, only to lose some of them to the city for neglect or unpaid taxes. So Brad thought it was only fair to give Dowl a shot at keeping his house. But Dowl failed to act. He didn't pay his back taxes, and the city went ahead and put his house up for auction. Brad picked it up for $10,000.
布拉德实际上和纳撒尼尔·道尔有一些共同点。两人都是在新奥尔良出生长大的。两人都在40多岁。两人的家庭都曾经在这里购买过投资性房产，只是因为疏忽或欠税而将其中一些输给了城市。所以布拉德认为给道尔一个保留房子的机会是公平的。但道尔没有采取行动。他没有补交欠税，城市继续拍卖他的房子。布拉德以1万美元买下了它。
A couple days after buying the house, Brad and two friends stopped by to check it out. He also wanted to disconnect the electric meter, which he worried could be a fire hazard.
买下房子的几天后，布拉德和两个朋友过去查看。他还想断开电表，他担心这可能会导致火灾隐患。
So we went to pull the meter, and the second I pulled the meter back out, he came running out the door.
所以我们去拔电表，我刚拔掉电表，他就从门口跑了出来。
And what did he say?
他说了什么？
Basically, he took a baseball bat, and threatened me, and threatened the other two people with me, and said he was sick and tired of the city taking his f-ing properties.
基本上，他拿了一根棒球棒威胁我，威胁和我在一起的另外两个人，说他受够了城市拿走他的该死的房产。
Did he come down off the steps?
他从台阶上下来了吗？
Yeah, he chased us out in the street. He was like a mad man.
是的，他把我们追到了街上。他像个疯子一样。
Brad called the cops who cited both men for disturbing the peace. Brad showed the police some papers proving that he had just bought the house, so the police told Dowl he had to leave. But Brad had a feeling it wasn't over.
布拉德报了警，警察因扰乱治安对两人进行了传唤。布拉德向警察出示了一些证明他刚买下房子的文件，所以警察告诉道尔他必须离开。但布拉德有一种预感，事情还没结束。
So I drove back, I think it was like 11 or 12 o'clock at night. And I saw his car parked there, and there was a light on inside the premises.
所以我开车回去，我想是晚上11点或12点左右。我看到他的车停在那里，里面有一盏灯亮着。
Brad called the cops again.
布拉德又报了警。
And they came out. And they knocked on the door, and they instructed Mr. Dowl that they had previously ordered him not to return to the property unless he was accompanied and yada, yada. And they placed him in handcuffs for criminal trespass. At that time, Mr. Dowl presented a document. It was a restraining order signed by Judge Paul Brown in Division M, so the police took the handcuffs off and allowed him to stay in the premises that night.
他们来了。他们敲门，指示道尔先生，他们之前已经命令他不要回到该处，除非有人陪同等等。他们给他戴上手铐，因刑事入侵。当时，道尔先生出示了一份文件。那是由M部门的法官保罗·布朗签署的限制令，所以警察解开了手铐，允许他当晚留在房子里。
None of this made any sense to Brad. Why would a judge sign a restraining order against him? After all, he hadn't done anything. Besides he owned the house.
这一切对布拉德来说毫无意义。法官为什么要签署针对他的限制令？毕竟，他什么也没做。此外，他拥有这所房子。
The next morning, I went to see Judge Brown to see why she signed this restraining order, TRO. And she had no recollection of signing it. She emphatically denied it. She had her clerk check her book. There was nothing in there. And then she actually walked me to each judge and asked them and their clerks if any other judge had signed her name to a TRO. And they all said no.
第二天早上，我去看布朗法官，看看她为什么签署这个临时限制令（TRO）。她根本不记得签过它。她断然否认了。她让书记员检查了她的书。里面什么都没有。然后她实际上带我走到每位法官面前，询问他们和他们的书记员，是否有其他法官签署了她的名字到TRO上。他们都说没有。
The TRO was a fake, and this is where Nathaniel Dowl's background comes in. Under the advice of his attorney, Dowl refused to talk to me. But here's what we know mostly through public records and court documents.
TRO是伪造的，这就是纳撒尼尔·道尔的背景发挥作用的地方。在他的律师的建议下，道尔拒绝与我交谈。但通过公共记录和法庭文件，我们大体了解了以下情况。
Throughout much of his life, Dowl ended up in court for stumbling onto the wrong side of the law for car theft, for pot, for unpaid debts. In 1988, he was sentenced to three years in prison for using bogus money orders. We also know Dowl used to own several houses, places he apparently inherited from his father, who invested his longshoreman salary in properties.
在他的大部分生活中，道尔最终因偷车、大麻、未偿债务等触犯法律而多次进出法庭。1988年，他因使用伪造汇票被判入狱三年。我们还知道道尔曾经拥有几所房子，这些地方显然是从他父亲那里继承的，他父亲把码头工人的薪水都投资在了房产上。
Somewhere along the line, Dowl started teaching himself law. He enrolled in a correspondence program and got his paralegal certificate. He learned the basics, what legal documents do, how to file them, what size the paper should be, how to make them look official. In fact, he learned enough that he could produce fake documents pretty easily.
在某个时候，道尔开始自学法律。他注册了一个函授课程并获得了法律助理证书。他学习了基础知识，法律文书的作用，如何提交它们，纸张应该是什么尺寸，如何使它们看起来正式。事实上，他学到的足够多，可以很容易地制作伪造文件。
Dowl had a couple of favorite scams. One was to take a bogus document to a notary and would stamp it with a seal. That only meant Dowl signed the document in person in front of the notary. But the seal made things look all the more official and gave the appearance that claims in the document had been verified.
道尔有几个最喜欢的骗局。一个是把伪造文件带给公证人，然后盖上印章。那只意味着道尔亲自在公证人面前签署了文件。但印章使事情看起来更加正式，并给人一种文件中的索赔已经过验证的印象。
Dowl also figured out how to make good use of a run-of-the-mill kind of legal document, which, and unless you're a lawyer, you've probably never heard of. It was something called a quitclaim. While it might sound obscure, the idea behind a quitclaim is pretty simple. Let's say you have the rights to a piece of property. You go to the courthouse and file a quitclaim giving those rights to, say, your cousin. So your cousin now has legal rights to that property.
道尔还搞清楚了如何利用一种平庸的法律文件，除非你是律师，否则你可能从未听说过。它被称为放弃所有权声明（quitclaim）。虽然它听起来晦涩难懂，但放弃所有权声明背后的想法很简单。假设你拥有某处房产的权利。你去法院提交一份放弃所有权声明，把这些权利交给，比如说，你的表亲。所以你的表亲现在拥有该房产的法律权利。
The trick that Dowl figured out was that he could file a quitclaim on any piece of property, whether he owned it or not. City officials would look at that document and figure he must have had some rights to begin with, because why else would he file it? And so essentially, Dowl found that armed with just a small bit of legal knowledge, he could trap pretty much anyone he wanted in an upside down topsy-turvy world where all sorts of basic things normally taken for granted just crumble out from beneath you.
道尔搞清楚的技巧是，他可以在任何房产上提交放弃所有权声明，不管他是否拥有它。城市官员会看这份文件，认为他肯定有一些权利，因为他为什么要提交它呢？所以本质上，道尔发现，只要掌握一点点法律知识，他几乎可以把任何他想困住的人困在一个颠倒的混乱世界里，在那里，所有通常被认为理所当然的基本事物都从你脚下崩塌。
Brad Robinson's war with Dowl started out small and kind of mundane. Brad sued to get Daniel evicted. Dowl challenged the city's right to take his property. The fight went to the state Supreme Court where Dowl lost. And for a while, Robinson's life went back to normal. But then Dowl started showing up in strange places, like the houses the Robinsons were working on, properties Dowl had never had anything to do with.
布拉德·罗宾逊与道尔的战争始于小事，有些平凡。布拉德起诉要求驱逐丹尼尔。道尔挑战城市收走他房产的权利。斗争一直持续到州最高法院，道尔在那里败诉了。有一段时间，罗宾逊的生活恢复了正常。但随后道尔开始出现在奇怪的地方，比如罗宾逊夫妇正在进行的项目中，道尔从未参与过的房产。
He would show up at the job sites and pretend to be a buyer of one of the properties and request whoever was there to walk through the property. And later on, if he would go down and create these false documents on every one of them.
他会出现在工作现场，假装是其中一处房产的买家，并要求在场的人带他参观房产。后来，如果他会去并在每处房产上创建这些虚假文件。
Dowl would file these bogus documents. Robinson would have to track them down and get them thrown out. And here's the thing. It wasn't like the city or the courts would call Robinson up and say, hey, Dowl came in again. Instead, Robinson had to be constantly watching.
道尔会提交这些虚假文件。罗宾逊不得不追踪它们并将它们扔掉。重点是。这并不是说城市或法院会给罗宾逊打电话说，嘿，道尔又来了。相反，罗宾逊必须时刻关注。
I lived down in the inventory archives going through records, because he'd file a document, and I'd go pay an attorney to do a mandamus to pull a document out, and then he'd go back and file another document. So I call him my paper stalker because he'd go down, it would cost me, say, $1,500 to hire a real attorney to do a mandamus, go in front of a judge, and the judge would make a ruling and know this was BS. And she would order the document pulled from the public record. And we did this for god knows how many years. And it was over, and over, and over.
我住在档案馆里查记录，因为他会提交一份文件，我就会花钱请律师做法院令（mandamus）来撤销一份文件，然后他会回去并提交另一份文件。所以我称他为我的纸上跟踪者，因为他会去，请一位真正的律师做一个法院令会花费我，比如说，1500美元，在法官面前陈述，法官会做出裁决，知道这是胡说八道。她会下令从公共记录中撤销该文件。我们这样做了一年又一年，天知道有多少年。它没完没了，一次又一次。
How many documents-- do you have any idea-- that you contested with him?
你和他就多少文件——你有概念吗——进行过抗辩？
I'll be honest with you, it was on, like, every piece of property he could find.
老实说，这几乎发生在他能找到的每一处房产上。
Dowl went after his old house, houses that Robinson was renovating, even after Robinson's family home.
道尔追逐他的旧房子，罗宾逊正在翻新的房子，甚至罗宾逊的家庭住宅。
I was somewhere. I was at a meeting or doing something, and my wife called me up in hysterics. I mean, absolute hysterics. She had come home from work with the children, and there was a notice to vacate posted on the door by a Sheriff's deputy. And she didn't know what it was about or what was going on. And she just went into total hysterics. So I went home, I got it, I went down there, and then I did a little research, and I found out it was my paper stalker again.
我当时在某处。我正在开会或做某事，我妻子歇斯底里地打电话给我。我的意思是，绝对的歇斯底里。她下班带着孩子们回家，门上贴着治安官副手贴出的驱逐通知。她不知道那是怎么回事，也不知道发生了什么。她变得完全歇斯底里。所以我回家了，我拿到了，我去了那里，然后我做了一些调查，我发现那又是我的纸上跟踪者。
What does it take to clear something like that up?
清理这样的事情需要什么？
We had to go to court. We had to hire another attorney.
我们不得不去法院。我们不得不雇佣另一位律师。
Over time, Dowl grew more brazen. At this point, he was just going after Brad with reams of paperwork. But he stepped things up with Tracy Poydras. She's the woman we talked to earlier, the woman who found her house covered with caution tape. Not only did Dowl file papers claiming he owned her house, he moved in.
随着时间的推移，道尔变得越来越猖狂。此时，他只是用成堆的文件去追逐布拉德。但他对特蕾西·波德拉斯采取了进一步行动。她是我们要早些时候提到的那个女人，发现自己的房子贴满了警戒胶带的那个女人。道尔不仅提交了声称拥有她房子的文件，他还搬了进去。
My mother-in-law went over to the house. And he told her that she couldn't come in. He told her that she couldn't come in. And so she thought, OK, I'm going to call the police. So she calls the police. And they tell her, he has some kind of document with, like, a seal on it. And she had some documents, and she's like, this man does not live here. This is my son's house.
我婆婆去了那所房子。他告诉她不能进去。他告诉她不能进去。所以她想，好的，我要报警。所以她报了警。他们告诉她，他有一些盖有印章的文件。她有一些文件，她说，这个男人不住在这里。这是我儿子的房子。
And the police were, like, OK, he showed us something saying that he should be in the house, so this is a civil matter. And you all have to go to court. We can't just remove him from the house. And he's in the background, like, making muscles and doing all kind of little stupid victory dances. And we were like, this is just not happening.
警察说，好的，他给我们看了一些东西说他应该住在房子里，所以这是一个民事案件。你们都必须去法庭。我们不能直接把他从房子里赶出去。他在背景中，像在展示肌肉，做各种愚蠢的胜利舞蹈。我们心想，这不可能发生。
This house has multiple defense perimeters. It's obvious that you see the shutter and the door, but you don't see all the other things.
这所房子有多道防御边界。很明显你看到了百叶窗和门，但你没看到所有其他的东西。
Meet the third person to get into this war with Nathaniel Dowl. Richard Arias is an attorney in his early 60s. He lives in a house that's dark inside because all the solid wood shutters are sealed tight. He explained to me that stems from a paranoia that dates back to his days as an infantryman in Vietnam. He knew both Nathaniel Dowl and Brad Robinson because he owned a house on Zimple Street next door to the one the two first fought over.
认识一下第三个卷入与纳撒尼尔·道尔这场战争的人。理查德·阿里亚斯是一位60多岁的律师。他住在一所里面很暗的房子里，因为所有的实木百叶窗都关得紧紧的。他向我解释说，这是源于一种偏执，可以追溯到他在越南担任步兵的日子。他认识纳撒尼尔·道尔和布拉德·罗宾逊，因为他在Zimple街拥有一所房子，就在他们两人最初争斗的那所房子隔壁。
Dowl was fighting Robinson, so Dowl came to me for help. Dowl knew that I was a lawyer, so he asked me for help.
道尔当时在和罗宾逊斗争，所以道尔来找我寻求帮助。道尔知道我是律师，所以他向我寻求帮助。
But that was pretty short-lived because it didn't take long for Dowl to turn on Arias, to decide Arias wasn't his ally, and to start serving him with fake paperwork and eviction notice, all of it. And the thing with Arias, he'd never bought any properties that Dowl once owned. With Arias, it was about vengeance, plain and simple. But regardless, he found himself in this paper war with Nathaniel Dowl.
但那相当短命，因为道尔没过多久就反过来针对阿里亚斯，决定阿里亚斯不是他的盟友，并开始向他发送伪造文件和驱逐通知，所有这些。而关于阿里亚斯的事情，他从来没有买过道尔曾经拥有过的任何房产。对于阿里亚斯，这纯粹是为了报复。但无论如何，他发现自己陷入了与纳撒尼尔·道尔的这场纸上战争。
He learned enough to make it look good. He would go to the courthouse and copy other people's work, change it enough, but not enough to correct typographical errors, not enough to remove references to standard forms, not enough to pass the scrutiny of a professional, like a judge. Well, just enough to get in the door.
他学到的东西足够让它看起来不错。他会去法院复制别人的工作，稍微修改一下，但没有修改到纠正排版错误，没有删除对标准表格的引用，没有通过像法官这样的专业人士的审查。嗯，刚好够进门。
This went on for more than four years, and Arias, the Poydrases, and the Robinsons all felt trapped. They went to the police, who told them it was a matter for the courts. They went to the courts, and the judges said they really couldn't do much, except reverse each fraudulent filing as it was presented to them. They went to the district attorney, who was struggling with the chaos left in the wake of Katrina and had didn't seem too interested in white collar crime.
这种情况持续了四年多，阿里亚斯、波德拉斯夫妇和罗宾逊夫妇都感到被困住了。他们去了警察局，警察告诉他们这是法院的事情。他们去了法院，法官说他们真的做不了什么，只能在每一份虚假申报提交给他们时将其撤销。他们去了地方检察官那里，他在卡特里娜飓风后的混乱中挣扎，似乎对白领犯罪不太感兴趣。
They even went to the court workers, the people who accepted Dowl's bogus documents when he filed them. The workers sort of shrugged and told them that even if they knew the documents were fake, they were bound by state law to accept them. At one point, Tracy's husband Oscar told her if the courts wouldn't help and the police wouldn't help, then they were on their own.
他们甚至去了法庭工作人员那里，那些在道尔提交伪造文件时接受它们的人。工作人员耸耸肩，告诉他们即使他们知道文件是伪造的，他们也必须根据州法律接受它们。有一次，特蕾西的丈夫奥斯卡告诉她，如果法院不帮忙，警察也不帮忙，那他们就只能靠自己了。
You're talking about a 6 foot 3, 300 pound man. He's like, OK, this is what I'm going to do. I'm going to go in the house with a bat, and I'm not going to hurt him. We're just going to run him out of there, you know? But I'm not going to hurt him. And I told him, you know what? It sounds good.
你在说一个6英尺3英寸、300磅重的人。他说，好的，这是我要做的。我要拿着球棒进房子，我不会伤害他。我们只是要把他赶出去，你知道吗？但我不会伤害他。我告诉他，你知道吗？这听起来不错。
So you do start to lose your mind because you're thinking, OK. Your sane mind is saying, I'm just going to go in there with this bat, and scare him off, and say, get out! Get out of my house. Well, what are you going to do if that doesn't work? What if he has a gun? You can't go in and do that.
所以你确实开始失去理智，因为你在想，好的。你理智的大脑在说，我只是要拿着球棒进去，把他吓跑，然后说，出去！滚出我的房子。好吧，如果那不管用你该怎么办？如果他有枪呢？你不能进去做那种事。
Then came the mounting costs of all this-- court fees, filing fees, not to mention that after Dowl moved in, the Poydrases had to pay two mortgages, but couldn't rent out their rental property because Dowl was living in it. But the people who felt the strain the worst were Brad and Michelle Robinson, who guessed that when you include court fees and lawyer fees, they ultimately spent about $90,000 on what was originally a $10,000 house.
随后而来的是所有这些带来的不断增加的成本——法庭费用、申报费用，更不用说在道尔搬进来后，波德拉斯夫妇必须支付两笔抵押贷款，却不能把他们的出租物业租出去，因为道尔住在里面。但感到压力最大的还是布拉德和米歇尔·罗宾逊，他们估计，如果你算上法庭费用和律师费，他们最终在一所最初价值1万美元的房子上花了大约9万美元。
The genius of Dowl's scheme was that he exploited the inertia of the legal system. Every time he filed a quitclaim, he was forcing the system to agree, just by taking the paperwork, that he had some rights to the property. And once the system accepts something as true, even for a moment, it's hard to make it go away. Do that over and over, and you're always a step ahead of your adversaries.
道尔计划的天才在于，他利用了法律系统的惯性。每次他提交放弃所有权声明时，他都强迫系统仅仅通过接受文书工作，就同意他对该房产拥有某些权利。一旦系统接受某事为真，即使只是一会儿，也很难让它消失。一遍又一遍地这样做，你总是领先你的对手一步。
And if Nathaniel Dowl hadn't slipped up, it's hard to say how long this all would have gone on. But Dowl finally tried his property trick on the wrong people-- the Feds. Brad Robinson discovered this after Katrina when he applied for federal money to do work on the house on Zimple Street.
如果纳撒尼尔·道尔没有出错，很难说这一切会持续多久。但道尔最终对错误的人——联邦政府——尝试了他的房产技巧。卡特里娜飓风后，布拉德·罗宾逊申请联邦资金在Zimple街的房子上做工作时发现了这一点。
I called Road Home Program, and they said, Mr. Dowl, you've already got money from this property. And I said, I'm not Mr. Dowl. And he said, oh, uh, well, Barbara Dowl got $137,000.
我打电话给Road Home计划，他们说，道尔先生，你已经从这个房产拿到了钱。我说，我不是道尔先生。他说，噢，呃，好吧，芭芭拉·道尔拿到了13.7万美元。
Using bogus property claims, Dowl's wife Barbara had applied for federal Road Home assistance. They got $132,000 on a property the Robinsons owned. That got the attention of the US Attorney's office. And soon Barbara Dowl was indicted by federal grand jury, and Nathaniel Dowl was charged with filing false public records. For a moment, the Robinsons, the Poydrases, and Arias thought they might get their lives back.
利用伪造的房产索赔，道尔的妻子芭芭拉申请了联邦Road Home援助。他们在罗宾逊拥有的房产上拿到了13.2万美元。那引起了美国检察官办公室的注意。很快，芭芭拉·道尔被联邦大陪审团起诉，纳撒尼尔·道尔被控提交虚假公共记录。有一瞬间，罗宾逊一家、波德拉斯一家和阿里亚斯以为他们可能会夺回自己的生活。
And then something really dark and crazy happened. Brad had a habit of going out late at night after his kids were asleep-- he liked to play poker-- and then coming home after midnight. But one night-- it was a couple days after Dowl found out he was being charged-- he happened to be in bed early.
然后发生了一些非常黑暗和疯狂的事情。布拉德习惯在孩子们睡着后深夜出去——他喜欢打扑克——然后在午夜后回家。但有一个晚上——那是道尔发现自己被指控后的几天——他碰巧早早躺在床上。
I was at home sleeping. I was in bed with my wife. About 10:30 that night, I'd gotten up and got a drink of water at my kitchen. You know, you get up and you get a drink without turning on the lights. Standing in my kitchen drinking a glass of water, and I heard somebody say, his name's Brad. I heard two people having a conversation in my driveway adjacent to my house.
我当时在家里睡觉。我和我妻子在床上。那天晚上10:30左右，我起床去厨房喝水。你知道，你起床喝水时不打开灯。站在厨房里喝着一杯水，我听到有人说，他叫布拉德。我听到两个人正在我家旁边的车道上交谈。
During this time, the Robinsons had someone staying with them, a friend of a friend named Tony White, who was an engineer from out of town working on some reconstruction projects. He didn't know a lot of people in this city, and most nights he worked late. This was one of those nights.
在这期间，罗宾逊夫妇有朋友住在一起，一个朋友的朋友叫托尼·怀特，他是一位来自外地的工程师，正在做一些重建项目。他在这个城市不认识很多人，大多数晚上他工作到很晚。这是其中一个夜晚。
2:00 in the morning, 2:30 in the morning, my wife was awakened by a phone call. And then she rolled over, and woke me up, and said that an elderly neighbor next door who was up late usually at night had heard something, and there was somebody laying in the street.
凌晨2点，凌晨2:30，我妻子被电话铃声吵醒了。然后她翻过身，叫醒我，说隔壁的一位老邻居通常晚上起得很晚，听到了一些动静，街上有人躺着。
Brad went outside.
布拉德出去了。
And right when I walked out the door, a police unit was pulling up. And I looked at the person, and he was laying face down, so I still didn't know who it was. I did not know who it was. And I walked down. I was in my pajamas, and I walked down. And I was about halfway down. I told my wife, I think it's Tony. But I wasn't sure, and I didn't know if he'd fallen, if he'd had a seizure, and I didn't know if he had a history of seizures or what. All these scenarios were running through my head.
就在我走出门口时，一辆警车停了下来。我看着那个人，他面朝下躺着，所以我仍然不知道他是谁。我不知道他是谁。我走过去。我穿着睡衣，我走了过去。我走了一半。我告诉我妻子，我想那是托尼。但我不敢肯定，我不知道他是否摔倒了，是否癫痫发作了，我不知道他是否有癫痫发作史。所有这些情景都在我脑海中闪过。
And I told my wife to bring the kids inside, so she brought the kids inside. And I knelt down over the body, and I felt his carotid artery. And when I reached down, he was-- there was no pulse whatsoever, so I knew he was dead.
我让我妻子把孩子们带进屋里，所以她把孩子们带进了屋里。我在尸体旁跪下，感受他的颈动脉。当我伸手下去时，他——根本没有脉搏，所以我知道他死了。
Tony White had been shot through his left eye at point blank range.
托尼·怀特在近距离被击中了左眼。
Let's be clear here. The crime is still unsolved, and the investigation never connected the shooting in any way to Dowl, or his wife, or anybody for that matter. And Dowl had an alibi. But there are things that still haunt the Robinsons about the shooting. Brad and Tony were about the same age, height, and build. The killers didn't bother with any of Tony's stuff. They took his car and burned it, but left behind his money and a bunch of expensive camera equipment. Brad's convinced that what happened at his house late that night wasn't just another random crime.
在这里明确一点。这起罪行仍未破案，调查没有将枪击事件与道尔、他的妻子或任何人联系起来。道尔有不在场证明。但关于这起枪击事件，有些事情仍然困扰着罗宾逊夫妇。布拉德和托尼年龄、身高和身材差不多。杀手没有动托尼的任何东西。他们拿走了他的车并烧毁了，但留下了他的钱和一堆昂贵的摄影器材。布拉德坚信那天深夜在他家发生的事情不仅仅是另一桩随机犯罪。
Nathaniel Dowl was eventually found guilty for filing fake public records. He's now serving a 10 year sentence, and his appeal was rejected late last month. Brad Robinson says he feels safer with Dowl in jail-- that's no surprise. But he also knows that in six years or so, Dowl will likely be getting out. He worries what will happen then.
纳撒尼尔·道尔最终被判定提交虚假公共记录罪名成立。他目前正在服10年刑期，他的上诉在上个月底被驳回。布拉德·罗宾逊说他觉得道尔在监狱里他更安全——那并不奇怪。但他也知道，大约六年左右，道尔可能会出狱。他担心那时会发生什么。
I think it's just a lull. He's only in jail for maybe, what, six years, 10 years. He might do six. And then he's going to get out, and he's going to come back and probably start up right where he left off, I would imagine. I think we've got a six-year reprieve. And I think when he comes out, he's going to come out with even a bigger vengeance.
我想这只是暂时的平静。他只坐牢了也许，什么，六年，10年。他可能会坐六年。然后他就会出狱，他会回来，我估计他可能会回到他离开的地方。我想我们得到了六年的缓刑。我想当他出来时，他会带着更大的报复出来。
Because of that fear, Robinson is planning to move his family out of New Orleans before Dowl gets released. Whatever does happen, then, even if it's over for the Robinsons, even if it's over for the Poydrases and Arias, it might not be totally over. Recently, Brad Robinson told me he happened to be looking at the city of New Orleans website, and he saw another one of Nathaniel Dowl's old properties up for sale by the city. Robinson says he feels sorry for whoever buys that place.
因为这种恐惧，罗宾逊计划在道尔释放前搬离新奥尔良。无论那时发生什么，即使对罗宾逊夫妇来说结束了，即使对波德拉斯夫妇和阿里亚斯来说结束了，它可能并没有完全结束。最近，布拉德·罗宾逊告诉我，他碰巧在浏览新奥尔良市网站，他看到另一处纳撒尼尔·道尔的旧房产被市政府出售。罗宾逊说他为买下那个地方的任何人感到遗憾。
Wayne Curtis, he's a contributor to The Daily Beast and Garden & Gun. Today's show is a rerun. Nathaniel Dowl died in 2013 shortly before he was due to be released from prison. The murder of Tony White remains unsolved.
韦恩·柯蒂斯是《每日野兽》和《花园与枪》的撰稿人。今天的节目是重播。纳撒尼尔·道尔于2013年去世，就在他即将从监狱获释之前。托尼·怀特的谋杀案仍未破案。
[MUSIC - TEENAGE FRAMES, "SIGN ON THE DOTTED LINE"]
[音乐 - TEENAGE FRAMES, "在虚线上签名"]
Act Three, I've Fallen in Love and I Can't Get Up. Sometimes you're a hostage inside your own body. Chris Higgins has this example, and we decided to rerun today's program this week because a movie is opening up this weekend based on this radio story. Anyway, here's Chris.
第三幕，我坠入爱河却无法站起。有时你是你自己身体里的人质。克里斯·希金斯有这个例子，我们决定在本周重播今天的节目，因为本周末有一部基于这个广播故事的电影开演。不管怎样，这是克里斯。
You know it's going to be a pretty weird interview when the first question is this. If you have an attack during this interview, what would you like me to do? I'm talking to Matt Frerking. He's 39.
你知道这将是一个相当奇怪的采访，当第一个问题是这样时。如果你在采访中发作了，你想让我做什么？我在和马特·弗雷金交谈。他39岁。
Well, if I fall over, then making sure that I can continue to breathe would be nice or that I haven't come to rest on something sharp or anything like that.
嗯，如果我摔倒了，那么确保我能继续呼吸会很好，或者我没有停在锋利的东西上之类的。
About four years ago, Matt started having these strange attacks. The first attack happened when he was taking a shower. His muscles began to feel heavy. His head began to droop. He slumped into a sitting position. He ordered his body to stand, but nothing happened.
大约四年前，马特开始有这些奇怪的发作。第一次发作是在他洗澡时。他的肌肉开始感觉沉重。他的头开始下垂。他瘫坐成一个坐姿。他命令他的身体站起来，但什么也没发生。
And so I was sitting there thinking, this is ridiculous. You can lift your head, move your arms, so just do it. And then just as quickly as it happened, a few minutes later, it went away. And I was back to normal and thought, wow, that was strange. And I went down and told my wife about it.
所以我坐在那里想，这太荒谬了。你可以抬起头，移动手臂，所以就这样做。然后就像它发生时一样快，几分钟后，它消失了。我回到了正常，想，哇，那真奇怪。我下去告诉我妻子这件事。
He just said I couldn't move. And I was thinking, well, he must be overstating it. You can't just not be able to move. That's just not something that really happens to people.
他说我无法移动。我在想，他一定是在夸大其词。你不能就是不能移动。这不是人们真正会发生的事情。
That's Trish, Matt's wife. They have four kids from her previous marriage, and some of those kids have kids of their own. It kept happening. Matt kept collapsing out of the blue every day, sometimes three and four times a day. He went to a string of doctors, including a psychiatrist, and a sleep doctor, and a neurologist. But none of them were able to fix the problem.
那是特里什，马特的妻子。他们有四个来自她前一段婚姻的孩子，其中一些孩子有了自己的孩子。这种情况一直发生。马特每天都毫无征兆地瘫倒，有时一天三四次。他看了许多医生，包括精神病医生、睡眠医生和神经科医生。但他们都没有能够解决这个问题。
Matt happens to be a neuroscientist. He's a professor at a university, but he was as baffled as everyone else. When each attack hit him, Matt was still totally conscious. He just couldn't move. Once on campus, he ended up flat on his back in a flower planter for over half an hour with his legs sticking out over the edge. He's fallen down stairs. He's had police and paramedics show up.
马特碰巧是一位神经科学家。他是一所大学的教授，但他和所有人一样感到困惑。当每次发作袭击他时，马特仍然完全有意识。他只是无法移动。有一次在校园里，他最终平躺在一个花坛里超过半小时，腿伸在边缘外。他从楼梯上摔下来过。警察和护理人员都出现过。
It took Matt three years to finally get a diagnosis. It turns out he has this disease called narcolepsy with cataplexy. That first part you've probably heard of. Narcolepsy is excessive sleepiness. You can treat that with stimulants. The real problem is the cataplexy, which is making him collapse. Worldwide, researchers estimate that more than a million people have this disease.
马特花了三年时间才最终得到诊断。事实证明，他患有一种叫做发作性睡病伴猝倒症的疾病。第一部分你可能听说过。发作性睡病是过度嗜睡。你可以用兴奋剂治疗。真正的问题是猝倒，这使他瘫倒。在全球范围内，研究人员估计超过一百万人患有这种疾病。
Although they're not sure why it's happening, they think it's related to REM sleep, the part of sleep when you dream. When you start dreaming, your brain tells you your muscles to go limp, so you don't act out the dream. That same signal was getting sent from Matt's brain, but it's happening while he's awake. So while the cause is hazy-- and by the way, there's no cure-- scientists have managed to figure out what triggers the attacks in most patients.
虽然他们不确定为什么会发生这种情况，但他们认为它与REM睡眠有关，即睡眠中你做梦的部分。当你开始做梦时，你的大脑告诉你的肌肉变得松弛，这样你就不会表现出梦境。同样的信号从马特的大脑发送出来，但它是发生在他清醒的时候。所以虽然原因模糊——顺便说一句，没有治愈方法——科学家们已经设法弄清楚了大多数患者发作的诱因。
The triggers vary, but the things that most reliably do it are strong emotions, and in particular, strong positive emotions. By and large, those are things that I either have to avoid or recognize that if I do them enough, they're going to trigger an attack.
诱因各不相同，但最可靠的诱因是强烈的情绪，特别是强烈的积极情绪。总的来说，那些是我必须避免或者认识到如果我做这些做得足够多，它们就会触发发作的事情。
Let me make sure you got that. When Matt gets really happy, when he feels the warm fuzzy stuff, he becomes paralyzed by his emotions-- literally paralyzed. This has been going on for four years, and there's no end in sight.
让我确保你听到了。当马特感到非常快乐时，当他感到温暖模糊的东西时，他就会被情绪所麻痹——字面意义上的麻痹。这种情况已经持续了四年，而且看不到尽头。
I mean, he told me once, yeah, this is such a sick disease because when I feel love for my wife, excitement at the grandkids, love for the kids, that sort of thing, it makes him have an attack.
我的意思是，他曾经告诉过我，是的，这是一种非常恶心的疾病，因为当我对我妻子感到爱，对孙辈感到兴奋，对孩子感到爱，诸如此类的事情时，它会让他发作。
So for example, when his littlest granddaughter had her second birthday party, Matt showed up. Kids were running around the living room. He was filled with the sentimental happy feelings anyone feels. And then he collapsed on the couch in the middle of a swarm of toddlers who weren't bothered by it. Matt can't even pet a puppy without collapsing.
所以例如，当他最小的孙女过两岁生日聚会时，马特去了。孩子们在客厅里跑来跑去。他充满了任何人都会感到的感伤的快乐心情。然后他瘫倒在沙发上，在一群不受此影响的幼儿中。马特甚至不能在不瘫倒的情况下抚摸小狗。
Weddings are just as bad. Matt's brother got married a few weeks ago, and Matt was there, happy for him, and therefore having an attack the whole time. He was propped against a wall, hoping people would ignore him and just go on with the wedding.
婚礼也一样糟糕。马特的哥哥几周前结婚了，马特在那里，为他感到高兴，因此一直在发作。他靠在墙上，希望人们会忽略他，继续举行婚礼。
Poor Matt. This was one of those things that it was just not OK for him to miss, even though we knew it would be difficult.
可怜的马特。这是即使我们知道会很困难，他也绝对不能错过的其中一件事情。
His wedding ceremony was a very small one. They wanted to take pictures of the whole group. Immediately after, my attack hadn't cleared up, so they all basically clustered around where I was propped up against the wall and included me. And so that was very sweet of them.
他的婚礼仪式是一个非常小的仪式。他们想给整个团体拍照。之后，我的发作还没消退，所以他们都基本上聚在我是靠在墙上的地方并把我包括进去。所以这太甜美了。
When you look at those pictures, what do you think?
当你看着那些照片时，你在想什么？
Oh, this was only a couple of weeks ago. I haven't actually seen them yet.
噢，这是仅仅几周前的事。我还没真正看到它们。
Are you concerned about it? It seems like it might be-- I don't know-- sort of strange, but also absolutely sweet.
你对此担心吗？这看起来可能——我不知道——有点奇怪，但也绝对甜美。
Yeah, and in honesty, I probably won't spend much time dwelling on those pictures because it makes it more difficult to not have an attack. It can be a triggering condition just to discuss it even.
是的，诚实地说，我可能不会花太多时间沉溺于那些照片，因为它使不发作变得更困难。甚至仅仅讨论它也可能是一种触发条件。
So at this moment, Matt is starting to have an attack. You can hear him slowing down and hesitating more.
所以在这一刻，马特开始发作了。你可以听到他在变慢和犹豫更多。
It's a bit harder to initiate movements, and I don't know if you've noticed or not. But I feel like my eyes are sort of drooping a bit, and so.
开始移动有点困难，我不知道你是否注意到了。但我感觉我的眼睛有点下垂，所以。
We talked for a little while more, and then Matt has to go lie down. It's half an hour before he's able to talk again. Matt's on medication now, and that medication helps him postpone the attacks. He has some warning before he loses control. And think about this. Matt had this attack while he was talking about a photograph he's never seen. If just talking about a picture can cause this, imagine all the other things Matt has to avoid.
我们谈了一会儿，然后马特不得不去躺下。半小时后他才能再次说话。马特现在正在服药，那种药能帮助他推迟发作。在失去控制之前他有一些警告。想一想。马特在谈论他从未看过的照片时发作了。如果仅仅谈论一张照片就能引起这个，想象一下马特必须避免的其他所有事情。
How does this affect your marriage?
这如何影响你的婚姻？
Well, profoundly, I guess, is really the way to put it. It's very difficult to allow myself to enjoy being with my wife.
嗯，深远地，我想，真的是这样。允许自己享受与妻子在一起的时光是非常困难的。
It's hard for me to have to either give up those things or not share them with Matt. It sucks, you know? How articulate of me. It's not a cool thing to happen to you.
我不得不放弃那些事情或者不与马特分享它们对我来说很难。真烂，你知道吗？我多么有表达能力。这不是一件发生在你身上很酷的事情。
Trish is pretty open about how she's come to deal with Matt's cataplexy and how it's changed their relationship. It messes up their social life and their sex life, too.
特里什非常坦率地谈论了她如何应对马特的猝倒症以及它是如何改变了他们的关系。它破坏了他们的社交生活和性生活。
It's hard to hear that my love-- and when you had those wonderful close moments, when you sit with your arms around one another and you just want to reflect on this is a pretty cool person I'm spending my life with, those make him sick. And sometimes what goes through my mind is a little guilt because is that fair to put him through that? And am I just doing it for myself?
听到我的爱——当你有了那些美妙亲密的时刻，当你坐在一起，双臂搂着对方，你只是想反思这是一个我共度一生的相当酷的人时，那些会让他生病。有时我脑子里闪过的是一点内疚，因为让他经历这些公平吗？我只是为了自己吗？
Trish is the only person who's really close to Matt these days. She told me that she reminds everyone that if Matt didn't care about them, this wouldn't be happening, that when he collapses, it's proof of his love. Their kids even have a kind of contest going to see who causes him to have more attacks to find out who his favorite is. They'll tease each other, like, did he pass out when you talked to him on the phone? 'Cause he passed out when I talked to him.
特里什是这些天真正接近马特的唯一一个人。她告诉我，她提醒每个人，如果马特不在乎他们，这就不会发生，当他瘫倒时，那是他爱的证明。他们的孩子甚至有一场竞赛，看谁导致他发作更多，找出谁是他的最爱。他们会互相打趣，比如，他和你通电话时晕倒了吗？因为他和我谈话时晕倒了。
And after living with this for four years, with being punished every time he experiences happiness, Matt's adapted, though the way he's adapted is sad. He tries to enjoy things less. He told me he tries to think of himself as a robot and not engage too emotionally. He's told me he even has to be careful with how he speaks, not to get too enthusiastic or worked up.
在忍受了这一切四年之后，每次体验快乐都会受到惩罚，马特适应了，尽管他适应的方式很悲哀。他试图减少享受事情。他告诉我，他试图把自己想象成一个机器人，而不是过于情绪化地投入。他甚至告诉我，他必须小心自己说话的方式，不要过于热情或激动。
When enjoyment and positive emotions cause you to basically be stuck in a state where you can't move, it doesn't take very long for you to find them quite a bit less enjoyable than they were before. So there's sort of a natural retraining that you do of how much to derive joy from things.
当享受和积极的情绪导致你基本上被困在一种无法移动的状态时，你不需要太久就会发现它们比以前的乐趣少了很多。所以有一种自然的重新训练，就是关于如何从事情中获取快乐。
But it's important to point out even though Matt is being trained by his brain every day not to feel these emotions, he still has them. He's still with Trish, and they make it work. Although Matt tries to avoid happiness, it's still a part of his life. He's proof that you can't avoid happiness. It'll find you no matter what. And Matt's lucky he has a wife who's standing by him. But for now, they're not holding hands.
但必须指出，即使马特每天都在被他的大脑训练不要感受到这些情绪，他仍然有它们。他和特里什在一起，他们让它发挥作用。虽然马特试图避免快乐，但它仍然是他生活的一部分。他是你无法避免快乐的证明。无论如何它都会找到你。马特很幸运他有一个妻子站在他身边。但目前，他们没有牵手。
Chris Higgins, he's the host of the Election Ride Home podcast. As I said earlier, a film is coming out this weekend that is a fictionalized story of somebody like Matt Frerking. The screenwriters basically heard this story on the radio and wrote a whole script that tries to imagine what it might be like to try to date and find love with this disease.
克里斯·希金斯是《选举回程》播客的主持人。正如我之前所说，本周末有一部电影上映，是一个像马特·弗雷金这样的人的虚构故事。编剧们基本上在收音机里听到了这个故事，并写了一个完整的剧本，试图想象试着约会和找到患有这种疾病的爱会是什么样子。
Like, what happens when you meet somebody who really makes you so joyful, and ecstatic, and therefore triggers these attacks? The film is called Ode to Joy. It stars Martin Freeman. It's in theaters right now in New York, and Los Angeles, and then lots more cities next weekend. And you can watch right now online on Amazon and iTunes.
比如，当你遇到一个真正让你如此快乐、狂喜，因此触发这些发作的人会发生什么？这部电影叫《欢乐颂》。它由马丁·弗瑞曼主演。它现在在纽约和洛杉矶的影院，然后下周末在更多的城市。你现在可以在网上亚马逊和iTunes上观看。
[MUSIC - WARREN ZEVON, "HOSTAGE-O"]
[音乐 - 沃伦·泽冯，《人质-O》]
Our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak and Ben Calhoun, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Marie, Sarah Koenig, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for today show is Julie Snyder, the music up from Jessica Hopper. Additional production on today's rerun from Jessica Lussenhop, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney. Special thanks today to Josh Bearman, Scott Carrier, Annie Baxter, Matt Malloy, Etgar Keret, and Douglas Robinson. Annie Correal's story in Act One was originally produced with funding from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
我们的节目今天由莉萨·波拉克和本·卡尔霍恩制作，亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、简·玛丽、萨拉·凯尼格、罗宾·塞米恩、阿利萨·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们今天节目的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德，音乐来自杰西卡·霍珀。今天重播的额外制作来自杰西卡·卢森霍普、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·纳尔逊和马特·蒂尔尼。今天特别感谢乔什·贝尔曼、斯科特·卡里尔、安妮·巴克斯特、马特·马洛伊、埃特加·凯雷特和道格拉斯·罗宾逊。安妮·科雷亚尔在第一幕的故事最初由公共广播公司资助制作。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to Public Radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. It is so distracting when he comes into the studio while I'm here reading the credits.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX传送给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。当我在阅读致谢名单时他进入工作室真的太分散注意力了。
And he's in the background, like, making muscles and doing all kind of little stupid victory dances.
他在背景中，像在展示肌肉，做各种愚蠢的胜利舞蹈。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - WARREN ZEVON, "HOSTAGE-O"]
[音乐 - 沃伦·泽冯，《人质-O》]